[Music]
thank you man this woman she looks like
a [ __ ] cave Drive hate to do this to
you but
day two of polar bear watch Michael is
taking us out an extraordinary Journey
to the sub-arctic and can everyone be
nice to me now exploring how climate
change is threatening the survival of
polar bears good morning again there
Michael
well you could hear that I thought it
was in my head
Royce just has that song
that's what Michael Strahan requested at
his funeral and they thought he was
going to be dead when they can't cut to
him
oh [ __ ] that's right and now we go live
to Manitoba to Michael Strahan who
[ __ ] yeah he's still alive good to see
you Mike how are you here he is so cold
out here
morning again Robin I promise I will
never complain about it being cold in
the studio ever again when I'm sitting
next to you I promise you that I'm just
kidding me out here in the tundra of
Churchill Manitoba you can't really see
because it's still dark out here
without being cold and George
Stephanopoulos just got [ __ ] tired of
it
watch this is gonna end with because
Stephanopoulos wants him dead right this
is going to end with him like hiring
some poachers to release polar bears
nearby to attack him and he's going to
get attacked live on the air by a polar
bear and and actually beat the polar
bear what movie was it was one of the
Narnia movies where like they rode polar
bears or something
he sets up a polar bear attack Michael
Strahan chokes the Polar Bear out and
then [ __ ] everybody's like oh my God
and he's like don't worry nobody be
alarmed he's just sleeping by the way
Alban albeda NYC in the in the rumble
chat says Strahan should have been the
New Black Panther yes
it would have been a better movie
oh [ __ ] I'd watch that oh [ __ ] and to
get here there are no direct roads to
the town the only way to get here is by
train or plane after flight so hear me
out
you want to be a climate activist so you
took a train to then a plane which used
fuel right to then take a huge bus which
uses a lot of fuel right to go see if
you can find polar bears and by the way
there's some smarter people that
commented on our video our clip earlier
and they go guys just so you know since
the 1950s the polar bear population is
quadrupled
FYI just since the 1950s there's more
by the way it's also Ben of Charles I
just saw this Cubans are just Dominicans
who have more home run power
that's true it's funny those Dominicans
are really good in the infield though
dude the best Golden Glove winners all
of them are Golden Glove winners if you
look at the list of Golden Glove winners
you think you're at a Puerto Rican
restaurant
[Laughter]
look all I know is if I'm around at
least five Golden Glove players I know
the food's gonna it's gonna be amazing
and they're all going to be serving but
it's going to be good and they're all
going to be drunk
hey bring me the good run from the back
bro you look good bro the one I brought
like back over yeah bring it bring it
over bro we're praying or plane after
flight to Manitoba the team and I
boarded a final flight bound that's not
true actually you could also travel by
polar bear but it's not recommended
so here's the thing you took two planes
to train an automobile and [ __ ]
everything a bus
well no we flew private oh that's even
worse for the environment at the crew
and all the equipment and stuff so we
well no actually
um they had well their home plane I flew
private and just like three producers
because I got to stretch my legs out
yeah and then the rest of them flew on a
different private jet with all the
equipment so which is the so-called
polar bear capital of the world to see
these majestic creatures in the wild
polar bears in the majestic creatures
you said are evaporating as we speak yes
those the ones that just said quadrupled
yeah so yeah it was amazing always loved
them maybe it's because we're about the
same size I don't know but but really
these Bears sir you're big but you're
not the same size as a polar bear okay
calm down they are breathtaking and they
need us to be breathtaking they're
breathtaking animals their environment
is rapidly changing
because people keep driving [ __ ]
and look like that
so let me guess
I'm driving a four-cylinder Volkswagen
and you're on the I'm the problem I'm
the problem oh cool that's awesome well
we had to take the bus because the
private jet wouldn't land where the pads
were but we did take a helicopter from
the private jet to the bus
it was only a three minute ride like
what but boy boy but boy was it worth it
they had a Nintendo switch on there you
couldn't get me off
dude it's like when we stayed in Vegas
we had the shitty view that one time oh
yeah yeah at the airport right and I was
like it was so funny seeing like these
private jets show up dudes get off a
private jet get into a helicopter and
then fly off to something and you're
like how much fuel did that just
it's like and it's never like it's
always like the [ __ ] joke from a
Silicon Valley it's never like if a
private jet holds eight dudes there's
never eight dudes in a private jet
there's always like three of them
remember when they raced you remember
they raced yes and they said do you play
chess so then they played they played
online chess on their phone instead of
going on this the Jackson Hole I think
they were flying a Jackson Hole in
Jackson Hole and they both got out and
he was like wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute you play chess and he's
like yeah and he's like what's your
username and then they both still got in
their own private jets
our adventure begins to board this time
to be fair links okay uh lee didn't mean
Mage or something
to be fair though like it would be fun
to be that level of Rich where you just
fly private all the times money is just
like no issue okay they're gonna be so
great if we were so rich that we had to
both be at a city for some appearance
and Royce is like look I'm leaving out
at like 9 A.M blah blah blah I'm like
I'll just get my own jet I want to sleep
for like two but I'll meet you there
we'll get lunch it's taking separate
private jet now I'm gonna sleep in a
little bit more there you go there's a
good one it's clamity out here it's all
clamity out here and then Lena mean maid
this polar bear is now safe from climate
change
see now Jesus Christ we can all agree I
can't we can all agree that the new a
new star has been born on this show
our new favorite number one guys
not safe from climate change
[Laughter]
we're down here so we could get the
polar bears abortion to fight climate
change
what
what
[Music]
yeah like he starts like seeing the
glitches in The Matrix oh and I got a
question so welcome if cow farts is
making the Earth bad why do we want more
polar bears do they not fought
but to the polar bear fart affect the
climate change because if we have too
many polar bears that's going to be a
lot of polar bear farts oh there's just
in he's just been fired he's Justified
for Good Morning America and he's in
rumbled exclusive Michael Strahan
and I'm just saying why is everybody
doing that to Kyrie he's a great athlete
I think he's a very polite gentleman
every time I see him and uh you know
these Jews are really just you know it
just got stuff do me a favor Spanish
flea go to the locals Checkers you have
to read it look at siraj's tip but you
have to read in a Michael Strahan's
voice you do it better than me he just
he donated a two bucks just scroll up
just a little bit
where where is my am I in oh [ __ ] me I'm
in my location here here I'll just I'll
just I'll send it I'll send you the
donation
it's fine it's fine it takes a second
but you it's it's even even here they go
I sent it on this one minute I'm in the
chat
um
Suraj let Michael Strahan cook
three three
great I am obsessed with Michael Strahan
yes the more we've been watching him
it's my new thing
I love this we set out on an ice Safari
searching for these great white Bears
there's nowhere else like this anywhere
in the world it was really it was a
little too warm in there because of all
the diesel fuel that we're using on the
heater inside the bus
you should have said you could smell the
fumes for now
it's just
where you can go and just see you know
polar bears up close from this kind of
distance
[Music]
polar bear's like holy [ __ ] a black guy
well Michael Strahan's so famous the
polar bears like he said
dude he was one of the best defensive
players of all time wow what's he doing
here
wasn't his brother in a wheelchair
the bear is just tapping on the thing
going hey aren't you like a first ballot
Hall of Famer and the Michael stranger
shoots him he just
uh would say my life is safe now
another one another polar bear says
Chris from climate change
next time I see it I can't
regulated me oh there he is right there
how amazing is that
wow look at that that is amazing I will
say this [ __ ] pears in general are
cool bro pairs are [ __ ]
them deceptively adorable how many
people you think had to learn the hard
way at first before remember when they
tried to [ __ ] frame Hank the tank
Frank remember Hank the tank the Big
Bear bro poor guy there had to be some
early humans that just thought oh wow
this guy's cute and then they just they
just got killed immediately and then
word had to get out like okay those guys
look really cute but [ __ ] leave for
me they will eat you they don't look
like it but they want to see like a
brown bear that just shows up and it's
like yeah and you see him waddling
around like ain't the tank and you're
like oh look at this guy you want to hug
him you're like please don't
mom for about you see all the videos of
like the Russian bears that like just
come up to people's windows and they're
like
you know I just feed them one like
calmly So Into You the Bears speak also
have a Russian accent of course they do
okay cool no that's cool are they riding
unicycles too
don't forget to Fez oh a little Fez on
their head
[Music]
now how long do they stay with Mom lean
did it again for two to three years
all right
oh [ __ ] man uh let's see straight hand
is a [ __ ] Legend on the show now
hey guys I found I found one
okay this is [ __ ] great now he has
him as a mouth which is great
and they made me the king
it's a monopolis again is just pissed
off she's always backfiring
I am now the king of the polar bears he
recognized me when I played on the
Giants
comes back he comes back to the studio
after this and insists that they put
they [ __ ] put in the Chiron Michael
King of the polar bear strain
turns out I'm royalty
maybe someday you could come with me
George I introduced you to the polar
bears
I hate this man can we send this guy to
the Center of the Earth
so it turns out that I ran into the mole
people and they also made me King laughs
[Music]
then they go to dirty dirty to the
Center of the Earth
star of Michael Strahan
riverways and then you're putting
Michael Strahan brings about world peace
forcing everyone uh I follow a one-world
government backed by his military of
mole people and polar bears oh great so
that's what that's who's gonna he's the
Antichrist great
Adventures I would love more than
anything it would be better than the
Mike Tyson event I think it actually
would be a polar bear survival it allows
the Bears to go far enough out to prey
on seals and store a fat to get them
through spring and summer because of
global warming after a one-hour
explanation on what the seal was I
finally understood they're like water
dogs
[Laughter]
I mean there are now shorter CI Seasons
which give the Bears less time to hunt
for food resulting in less than I'd give
Michael Strahan a [ __ ] nature [ __ ]
show
he should replace David Attenborough
planet Earth it would be amazing planet
Earth
planet Earth yeah
I'd watch it man I love this man
I can't shorter CI Seasons which give
the Bears less time to hunt for food
resulting and more time the home for
football players
uh-oh that's me
well it looks like Michael's got him
another prickly situation healthy bears
and if female Bears don't get enough
food sidekick like a Komodo dragon that
he calls hissy yeah something like that
he needs a sidekick can't maintain their
weight well they sent me to space and
they sent aliens after me but then the
aliens also elected me they're King
they were very impressed by my physical
prowess
let's see resulted in fewer polar bears
worldwide how do they know when when
okay this is the time to go they'll go
out and they start testing it spreading
their paws out and as soon as there's
enough ice there was covered in blood
yes because he probably killed another
[ __ ] polar bear Fergie these polar
bears are [ __ ] brutal animals okay
piling up polar bear bodies you're right
it's [ __ ] pile of bodies to be out
hunting seals they're gone
Ahoy we meet up with buggy one polar
bear International's Tundra office on
Wheels and we arrived to it which by the
way shockingly cuts a lot less than a
kova 19 graphic designer in L.A
yeah who can afford that the Bounty of
bears we're here he's so he's a child
dude look at the child like Wonder Man
that's why I like it I I can't hate it I
just I just with him
we're here I'm so excited
it's just it's it's it's weird because
he was you gotta understand For You
younger people who may not have like
remembered Michael Strahan as a football
player this guy is a [ __ ] animal in
his prime like he was a [ __ ]
defensive animal and I don't think any
of us pictured this it's just this sweet
[ __ ] child inside
somebody made a better one
depressed Ron Paul in the locals chat
today on planet Earth we say the polar
bears from climate change
[ __ ] great
got two polar bears that would say
laying in the Sun
but no they're laying in the cold
but they look cute from up here we got
another polar bear over there a little
more active not just laying down like oh
the polar bears
[ __ ] like the other two
but they are big beautiful
come like me
guys come on look at that smile all
right Strahan is now your ear in man
you're our guy now see look I get it you
got to push a bunch of [ __ ] globalist
properly which sucks obviously you know
you you hang out with [ __ ] George
Stephanopoulos and he [ __ ] sucks
anybody who makes George Stephanopoulos
sad rules like this like you said this
Forest Gump comes in and it becomes the
sweetheart of Good Morning America the
guy who used to break bones in the
football field
inside this buggy the team is presenting
research via live stream to the United
Nations climate change conference at
sharmo Shake Egypt we really can make a
difference truly scientist Elisa McCall
now this Egypt Havelock sand bears okay
yeah they got Dan somethings okay
calm down
[Laughter]
pull it back Dr Virgie duke it was the
tone of it like I'm saying something
also this this polar bear [ __ ] kind of
cute I didn't realize
Chief scientist Dr Stephen amstrup the
Pioneer not him polar bear research
report on the increasing threat of
climate change to Polar Bear quadrupled
since the 50s what are the methods that
you wanted to convey there we're here
talking about polar bears and melting
sea ice and connecting that to societies
around the world outside we see two
polar bears sparring they're kind of
testing each other's prowess who's the
toughest this time of year it's oh no
they're having sex
they're having sex yep nope yeah pretty
sure yeah we're having polar bear sets
that's two gay bears oh boy
you know look guys I'm not gonna lie to
you it's not the climate change these
Bears have been really gay lately and we
can't get him to reproduce they keep
just having all this gay butt sex trying
to practice it off with the butt sex
already and then hopefully and pandas
never want to [ __ ] those two little
timid pandas remember those toys trading
at pandas the [ __ ] they just never do
yeah Bob knows hey that guy's a lot
tougher than I am I'm not even gonna
mess with him so if uh hypothetically
beat up a polar bear well they know that
I am tougher than them
ever sounds like life well
and they're here just waiting for the
eye shelf to freeze over that's right
yeah but now because of climate change
it's a little bit later in the season
that they're able to go out but it also
quadrupled since the 50s oh yeah and by
the way Seasons aren't do they do these
climate change reporters people they do
you understand right that season's
slightly vary right yeah we don't just
get like the same Truman Show weather
every day right like it's yeah it's like
sometimes you have a little bit of a
particularly cold season sometimes you
get a warmer season sometimes you
[ __ ] summer lasts a little longer or
your [ __ ] winter lasts a little
longer like there's always slight
variations like we have an idea of
what's supposed to be the deal but calm
down